其他人：什么东西
Other: What is this?
其他人： 2分钟之前打电话
Other: Called two minutes ago
其他人：你还没接你还
Other: You didn't pick up, you still
其他人：方向然后再往回走
Other: Change direction then head back
其他人：说走咱就走啊
Other: Said let's go, then we go
Shure: 哦走出去了这个
Shure: Oh, we're out now
Jake:我那个要扫房间
Jake: I need to sweep the room
Jake:然后你你你这个屋子我就这么扫了
Jake: Then I'll just sweep this room like this
Shure: 啊啊可以可以
Shure: Ah, ah, that's fine, that's fine
Jake:挺挺挺有艺术感
Jake: Quite artistic
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's good
Shure: 好嘞好嘞
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure: 拜拜嗯
Shure: Bye-bye, mm.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Shure: 什么他要扫房间
Shure: What? He wants to sweep the room?
其他人：啊
Others: Ah?
Shure: 什么他要扫房间
Shure: What? He wants to sweep the room?
其他人：扫呗所以呢
Others: Sweep, so what?
Shure: 不是是扫描的扫哦哦
Shure: No, I mean scan, like with a scanner.
其他人：你快给我原话
Others: Give me the exact words.
其他人：你快给我原
Others: Give me the exact...
Shure: 把自己个这搭了个歌棚还是什么玩意
Shure: He built himself a recording studio or something.
其他人：你快给我原
Others: Give me the exact...
其他人：咦我跟你圆
Others: Hey, I'll explain it to you.
Shure: 好你放心我这话肯定能给你圆回来
Shure: Don't worry, I'll definitely explain it to you clearly.
Shure: 我办事你还不放心吗
Shure: Don't you trust me to handle it?
其他人：不放心
Others: No, I don't.
其他人：就是你办事我才不放心开玩笑
Others: It's precisely because you handle it that I don't trust it, just kidding.
Shure: 我办事呢
Shure: I'm handling it.
Shure: 呵呵我草
Shure: Haha, damn.
Shure: 这衣服可以我的了
Shure: This outfit looks good, it's mine now.
Shure: 以后咱俩衣柜就换了
Shure: From now on, we'll swap wardrobes.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright?
Shure: 明儿给我两条裙子穿着
Shure: Give me two dresses to wear tomorrow.
其他人：我有点我有点嫌弃你的衣柜
Others: I'm kind of repulsed by your wardrobe.
Shure: 我衣柜怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with my wardrobe?
其他人：想用我
Others: Want to use mine?
Shure: 什么叫小鹦鹉
Shure: What do you mean by small parrot?
Shure: 鹦鹉也有玄凤
Shure: There are cockatiels too.
Shure: 纯白的是吧
Shure: Pure white ones, right?
其他人：后面那个鹦鹉是休老师吗
Others: Is that parrot behind you, Teacher Shure?
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 神经病哈哈
Shure: Crazy, haha.
其他人：这拐还是出去拐
Others: Should we turn here or go out?
Shure: 出去拐出去拐
Shure: Go out, go out.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 这边能出去吗可以
Shure: Can we go out this way? Yes.
Shure: 那边能进来吗
Shure: Can we enter from there?
Shure: 啊能
Shure: Ah, yes.
Shure: 准备从这出来过
Shure: Get ready to come out from here.
Shure: 俩俩一人一个
Shure: Two by two, one for each.
Shure: 这个我觉得可以
Shure: I think this is doable.
Shure: 一会穿上
Shure: Put it on later.
其他人：这个应该是可以的
Others: This should be fine.
Shure: 两人进屋
Shure: Two people go inside.
Shure: 你先换装配好吧
Shure: You change first and get ready.
其他人：啊应该没什么问题
Others: Ah, there should be no problem.
其他人：因为我买衣服都是那种偶尔size
Others: Because I buy clothes that are occasional sizes.
Shure: 不是偶尔size
Shure: Not occasional sizes.
Shure: 就是分不出来啊
Shure: It's just hard to tell apart.
Shure: 没有很强的性别指向
Shure: There's no strong gender indication.
Shure: 那这个怎么回事呢
Shure: So what's the deal with this?
其他人：哪个
Others: Which one?
Shure: 这个小粉裙
Shure: This pink dress.
其他人：因为它是裙子哦
Others: Because it's a dress.
其他人： 我就这么被一点点晒黑的
Others: I got tanned bit by bit like this.
Shure: 那我怎么还没有呢
Shure: Then why haven't I?
Shure: 真是吃叶黄素吃的感觉
Shure: It feels like I've been eating too much lutein.
Shure: 你不是黑
Shure: You're not dark.
其他人：啊
Shure: 你这真的是黄
Shure: You're really yellow.
Shure: 哈哈有可能
Shure: Haha, maybe.
其他人：不吃了不吃了
Others: Not eating anymore.
Shure: 有可能你脑子里面就是太多了
Shure: Maybe you have too much of it in your brain.
其他人：真的是黄吗
Others: Is it really yellow?
其他人：黄吗因为我自己我看不出来
Others: Yellow? Because I can't tell myself.
Shure: 我自己我
Shure: I myself...
其他人：我就觉得是晒黑影好
Others: I just feel like it's a tan.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 那有可能我的这个人种不太正确吧
Shure: Maybe my race is not quite right.
Shure: 可能
Shure: Maybe.
其他人：哎呦晒黑了
Others: Oh, got tanned.
其他人：晒晒黄了啊
Others: Got tanned yellow.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa.
其他人：又开始红
Others: It's starting to get red again.
Shure: 为什么红
Shure: Why red?
其他人：讨厌太阳紫外线
Others: Hate the sun's UV rays.
其他人：看到了彩票啊
Others: Saw the lottery.
Shure: 哦这就有一个
Shure: Oh, there's one here.
Shure: 得亏你眼前
Shure: Luckily it's right in front of you.
Shure: 不然我直接过去
Shure: Otherwise, I'd have gone straight over.
Shure: 然后开始拐弯了
Shure: And then we start turning.
Shure: 从哪上去
Shure: Where do we go up?
其他人：要上去吗
Others: Do we need to go up?
Shure: 他应该是个二楼吧
Shure: It should be on the second floor, right?
Shure: 你好这彩票站怎么上去
Shure: Hello, how do we get to this lottery shop?
Shure: 彩票站这个彩票站在哪
Shure: Where is this lottery shop?
其他人：彩票站啊
Others: Lottery shop, huh?
其他人：不知道啊
Others: No idea.
Shure: 好谢谢
Shure: Okay, thanks.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 往里走走看看
Shure: Let's walk inside and check.
Shure: 还是说这里面就是啊
Shure: Or is it just here?
Shure: 就是烧烤店
Shure: It's a barbecue place.
Shure: 加彩票站
Shure: Plus a lottery shop.
Shure: 没这么离谱吧
Shure: Can't be this ridiculous.
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nope.
其他人：这是后厨了
Others: This is the kitchen.
Shure: 哎呦呦呦
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 奇怪而且导航没没给我这的
Shure: Weird, and the navigation didn't lead me here.
Shure: 有彩票站
Shure: There's a lottery shop.
其他人：啊那就在这里面 就走呗
Others: Ah, then it's inside here. Let's go.
其他人：西瓜买个西瓜回去吧
Others: Let's buy a watermelon to take back.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
其他人：你抱着
Others: You carry it.
Shure: 我抱着可以一会一会回来的
Shure: I can carry it. We'll be back soon.
其他人：回去杀西瓜
Others: We'll cut the watermelon when we get back.
Shure: 好要杀掉
Shure: Okay, let's cut it.
其他人：要杀死星期一一样杀掉他
Others: We'll cut it like it's Monday.
Shure: 好那西瓜名就叫这名了
Shure: Okay, then we'll name the watermelon "Monday".
Shure: 好吧星期一
Shure: Alright, Monday.
Shure: my name is called Monday
Shure: My name is called Monday.
Shure: Monday yeah Monday
Shure: Monday, yeah, Monday.
Shure: 还是这么溜达舒服
Shure: It's still comfortable to stroll like this.
其他人：吊儿郎当
Others: Lazy and casual.
其他人：没个正形对
Others: Not serious at all.
Shure: 好兄弟这是
Shure: Good buddies here.
Shure: 道闪亮在呦
Shure: The path is shining.
Shure: 不行要放点放点
Shure: No, we need to play some music.
Shure: 5条人这氛围太太适合了
Shure: Five people, the atmosphere is perfect.
Shure: 我来
Shure: I'm on it.
其他人：你就只是你没电了
Other people: You're just out of battery.
其他人：你就只是穿了我一件衣服而已
Other people: You just wore one of my clothes, that's all.
Shure: 别管
Shure: Don't worry about it.
其他人：春天小姐是叫这名吗是吗
Other people: Is her name Miss Shen Tian? Is that right?
其他人：袁艾琳秀才
Other people: Yuan Ailin Scholar
其他人：哎这首歌真的超级牛
Other people: Wow, this song is really awesome.
Shure: 袁艾琳秀才
Shure: Yuan Ailin Scholar
Shure: 你放
Shure: You play it.
Shure: 我居然还没关注5条人
Shure: I can't believe I haven't followed 5 Tiao Ren yet.
其他人：对春天小姐
Other people: Yes, Miss Chun Tian.
Shure: 刘森我也没关注啊
Shure: I haven't followed Liu Sen either.
其他人：刘森滚圈大兵
其他人：过马路没有
Shure: 哎呦我靠
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 过
Shure: Move on.
其他人：天天边吃
Other people: Eating all the time.
Shure: 他是有扬琴
Shure: He has a Yangqin.
其他人：就是就是雨来临
Other people: Yes, yes, the rain is coming.
其他人：秀才就是那个雨
Other people: Scholar, it's that rain.
Shure: 哒哒哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da da da.
其他人：你想想纯靠木吉他能达到这种程度
Other people: Can you imagine achieving this level with just an acoustic guitar?
其他人：多牛啊
Other people: So impressive.
其他人：哦他这种
Other people: Oh, he’s like this.
Shure: 怎么了没有
Shure: What's wrong? Nothing.
其他人：我刚刚看到一个
Other people: I just saw one.
其他人：就是被挡住了
Other people: It was blocked.
其他人：看到一个什么什么哥
Other people: I saw something, something brother.
其他人：然后我以为就是那种饭店啊
Other people: Then I thought it was that kind of restaurant.
Shure: 赛哥
Shure: Sai Ge.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
其他人：怎么了
Other people: What’s wrong?
Shure: 没事
Shure: Nothing.
Shure: 我老了不会也开始养鸽子吧
Shure: When I get old, will I start raising pigeons too?
其他人：哈哈没关系
Other people: Haha, it's okay.
其他人：你就是
Other people: You are...
Shure: 什么是我是我是吗
Shure: What, I am, I am?
Shure: 我是我是我哥
Shure: I am, I am my brother.
Shure: 养你是吧
Shure: Raising you, right?
其他人：就莫名其妙
Other people: Just weird.
其他人：这首歌
Others: This song
其他人：其实算是伍条人我最喜欢的一首
Others: is actually my favorite by Wu Chaoren.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
其他人：就很莫名其妙
Others: It's just so inexplicable.
其他人：但是就嗯我也不知道为什么
Others: But, uh, I don't know why.
Shure: 啊回去一定要搞杯咖啡喝
Shure: Ah, I definitely need to get a cup of coffee when I go back.
Shure: 啊这个这个这个这个这个这个也
Shure: Ah, this, this, this, this, this one too.
Shure: 小罗也经常用
Shure: Xiao Luo often uses this too.
其他人：这歌听着都累
Others: Just listening to this song is exhausting.
其他人：不知道弹起来有多累
Others: Can't imagine how tiring it is to play.
其他人：热卖中哈哈哈哈
Others: Selling hot, hahaha.
Shure: 哪的哪的
Shure: Where, where?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 完了哎哎
Shure: Done, hey hey.
Shure: 还在还在
Shure: Still going, still going.
其他人：他就是循环
Others: It's just on repeat.
其他人：小屁股扭的吓我一跳
Others: That little butt shake scared me.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my gosh.
其他人：因为下面有狗所以上面狗在叫
Others: Because there's a dog below, so the one above is barking.
其他人：你看上面的那个黑的有点像小
Others: Look, the black one up there looks a bit like...
其他人：有点像藏獒
Others: a Tibetan Mastiff.
Shure: 我靠你刚才呜一声
Shure: Oh my gosh, did you just whimper?
Shure: 我以为我旁边哪来了一个狗
Shure: I thought there was a dog next to me.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
其他人：没了 6分钟
Others: It's done. 6 minutes.
其他人：6分14秒
Others: 6 minutes and 14 seconds.
Shure: 在一个
Shure: Another one.
Shure: 啾啾啾
Shure: Pew pew pew.
Shure: 完了我刚才打开手机要干嘛来着
Shure: Oh no, what was I going to do on my phone just now?
Shure: 哦给栗子发过去
Shure: Oh, send it to Lizzie.
其他人：（歌词）爱上了阿强
Others: (Lyrics) Fell in love with Ah Qiang.
Shure: （歌词）在一个有星星的夜晚
Shure: (Lyrics) On a starry night.
Shure: （歌词）人生
Shure: (Lyrics) Life...
Shure: （歌词）已经没有什么意义
Shure: (Lyrics) has no meaning anymore.
Shure: （歌词）更加魅力
Shure: (Lyrics) More charm.
其他人：哦我那天才发现我一直唱错了
Others: Oh, I just realized I've been singing it wrong all along.
其他人：就是他那个那个万千那首歌的调
Others: It's actually the tune of that song "Wan Qian".
其他人：前面是嗯自然则有余噔噔
Others: The beginning is, um, "Nature has its surplus, dun dun dun."
其他人：然后后面是个呃天安科后生城
Others: And then the back is "Tian An Ke Hou Sheng Cheng."
其他人：我一直唱的是下去的
Others: I've always sung it going down.
其他人：我一直是和自然自语唱一个调
Others: I've always been singing in harmony with nature.
其他人：结果后来发现哦
Others: But then I found out...
其他人：他后面是不一样的吗
Others: His part is actually different?
其他人：不一样的
Others: Yeah, it's different.
其他人：对他两个是不一样的
Others: Yeah, the two parts are different.
Shure: 原来这样
Shure: Oh, I see.
其他人：确实他那个丰富了一下
Others: Yeah, he really added some richness there.
其他人：（歌词）飞机将童年飞过流星夜
Others: (Lyrics) The plane flies over the childhood meteor night.
其他人：（歌词）漂泊的夜空
Others: (Lyrics) Drifting in the night sky.
其他人：（歌词）虽然说
Others: (Lyrics) Even though...
其他人：（歌词）人生
Others: (Lyrics) Life...
其他人：（歌词）并没有什么意义
Others: (Lyrics) Has no real meaning.
其他人：哦这边有一个小甲虫鞋店
Others: Oh, there's a small beetle shoe store here.
其他人：在化妆这块
Others: In the makeup section.
其他人：但具体位置是哪
Others: But where exactly is it?
其他人：我不知道
Others: I don't know.
其他人：你为什么突然笑一下
Others: Why did you suddenly laugh?
Shure: 怎么又这么了解了呢
Shure: How do you know so much about this?
其他人：因为之前记过啊
Others: Because I remembered it from before.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, got it.
Shure: 原来是这样
Shure: Oh, so that's how it is.
其他人：我今年夏天我要把自己晒黑哈哈哈
Others: This summer, I'm going to get a tan, haha.
其他人：不是晒红晒
Others: Not a sunburn.
Shure: 黑变吉克隽逸是吧
Shure: You want to turn as dark as Jike Junyi, right?
其他人：什么呀晒不成那样的
Others: No way, I can't get that dark.
其他人：你们还是不要黄成这个样子好吗
Others: You guys shouldn't get too yellow either, okay?
其他人：叶黄素真的会让人变成这样吗
Others: Does lutein really turn you this yellow?
Shure: 我觉得可能真的会
Shure: I think it probably does.
其他人：我知道他啊哈
Others: I know him, haha.
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn.
其他人：是这吗不是
Others: Is this the place? No?
Shure: 我那天不是这啊
Shure: Wasn't it here that day?
Shure: 那天那比这远
Shure: That day it was farther.
Shure: 所以我寻思找个近
Shure: So I thought I'd find somewhere closer.
其他人：你再再再搜
Others: Keep searching.
其他人：2米 250米
Others: 2 meters... 250 meters.
Shure: 再走我真的是吐了呀
Shure: If we walk any more, I'm gonna puke.
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ahhh.
Shure: 嘟嘟嘟嘟
Shure: Doo doo doo doo.
Shure: 啊我的朋友要结婚啦
Shure: Ah, my friend's getting married!
其他人：通州特产
Others: Tongzhou specialty.
Shure: 呵呵呵怎么独立了呢
Shure: Haha, how did it become independent?
其他人：夏天特别好穿
Others: It's great to wear in summer.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
其他人：它那个料子是滑滑的那种
Others: The material is very smooth.
其他人：还有兜很深的兜
Others: And it has deep pockets.
Shure: 磨磨起球了
Shure: It pills after some wear.
其他人：（歌词）问题出现我再告诉大家
Others: (lyrics) If there's a problem, I'll tell everyone.
其他人：（歌词）所有年轻人年轻人年轻人
Others: (lyrics) All the young people, young people, young people.
其他人：妈呀宝宝你是一只小猫
Others: Oh my, baby, you're a little cat.
Shure: 哈哈哈猫不理你
Shure: Hahaha, the cat ignores you.
其他人：干嘛
Others: What are you doing?
其他人：它看我了一眼
Others: It glanced at me.
Shure: 哈哈哈我又想起了那个烂狗
Shure: Hahaha, it reminds me of that lousy dog.
其他人：什么烂狗
Others: What lousy dog?
Shure: 狗不离心男
Shure: A dog that doesn't leave a man's heart.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 可以给我背回去吗
Shure: Can you carry me back?
Shure: 我好困真的吗真的
Shure: I'm so sleepy, really, really.
Shure: 那他们要笑话我怎么办
Shure: What if they laugh at me?
其他人：那就笑呗
Others: Then let them laugh.
其他人：我也笑话你
Others: I'll laugh at you too.
其他人：（歌词）大声告诉大家
Others: (lyrics) Tell everyone loudly.
其他人：（歌词）我的朋友他回来了
Others: (lyrics) My friend, he is back.
Shure: （歌词）告诉大家
Shure: (lyrics) Tell everyone.
Shure: 然后我的朋友结婚了
Shure: And then my friend got married.
Shure: 我就去给他们唱这个
Shure: I went to sing this for them.
其他人：半死不活唱是吧对
Others: Singing half-heartedly, right?
Shure: （歌词）告诉大家
Shure: (lyrics) Tell everyone.
Shure: 看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
其他人：什么看到了吗
Others: See what?
Shure:  看我看到彩票站了吗
Shure: Did you see the lottery store?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Shure: 我的发
Shure: My hair...
Shure: 还没到嗯
Shure: It's not there yet, hmm.
Shure: 这要再没有咱们就回去吧
Shure: If it isn't there, let's go back.
其他人：就是说明你命里不该有这份生日礼物
Others: It just means that this birthday gift isn't meant for you.
Shure: 我我就是这命里
Shure: It's just my fate.
Shure: 老天帮我省20块钱
Shure: Heaven saved me 20 yuan.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahahaha.
其他人：这样子啊
Other people: Oh, I see.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
其他人：今天星期一我看到了
Other people: It's Monday today, I saw it.
Shure: 哪呢
Shure: Where?
其他人：就这啊
Other people: Right here.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 那个有刮刮乐吗
Shure: Do you have scratch-off tickets?
其他人：没有没没
Other people: No, no, we don't.
其他入s:：走吧买西瓜去
Other: Let's go buy a watermelon.
Shure: 回去吧那就
Shure: Let's go back then.
其他人：从这边过不去吗
Other people: Can't we go through here?
Shure: 好像
Shure: Seems like it.
其他人：导航导航
Other people: Use navigation.
Shure: 原路返回吧
Shure: Let's go back the same way.
Shure: 原路返回
Shure: Go back the same way.
Shure: 导航肯定也是一样的
Shure: The navigation will probably say the same thing.
其他人：对
Other people: Yes.
Shure: 这好不智能
Shure: This isn't smart at all.
Shure: 皇家新村
Shure: Royal New Village.
Shure: 31号楼
Shure: Building 31.
其他人：31 嗯
Other people: 31, yeah.
其他人：31
Other people: 31.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：31还是513131
Other people: 31 or 513131?
Shure: 3131
Shure: 3131.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
其他人：呀还刚那个啊
Other people: Oh, that one.
其他人：啊那还有导航吗
Other people: Ah, do we still need navigation?
Shure: 你刚刚就来了就
Shure: You just got here.
Shure: 呵呵呵你说的有道理
Shure: Haha, you make a good point.
Shure: 沙滩上
Shure: On the beach.
Shure: 干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 现在红了
Shure: Now it's red.
Shure: 我怎么这么白呀
Shure: Why am I so pale?
Shure: 尤其跟你在一起
Shure: Especially next to you.
其他人：我变黄了
Other people: I've turned yellow.
Shure: 我真的好白呀我的妈
Shure: I'm really pale, oh my god.
其他人：是啊就是啊
Other people: Yeah, exactly.
Shure: 差太远
Shure: Such a big difference.
Shure: 哒啦哒哒
Shure: Da la da da
Shure: 哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da
其他人：真的要搜一搜
Others: Should we really search for it?
其他人：吃叶黄素会让人变黄吗
Others: Does eating lutein make you turn yellow?
Shure: 我帮你问
Shure: I'll ask for you
Shure: 卧槽1% 好
Shure: Oh crap, 1% battery left, okay
其他人：你别问了
Others: Don't bother asking
其他人：要没电了
Others: It's almost out of battery
Shure: 我要失联了
Shure: I'm gonna lose connection
其他人：不对呀不对
Others: That's not right, no
Shure: 我有充电宝
Shure: I have a power bank
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Ah hahahaha
其他人：这俩人快点快点
Others: You two hurry up, hurry up
Shure: 我他妈居然忘了这么高级的功能
Shure: I can't believe I forgot such an advanced feature
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh
其他人：充上了吗
Others: Is it charging?
Shure: 充上了走吧
Shure: It's charging, let's go
Shure: 吃太多GPT
Shure: Eating too much GPT
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahahaha
其他人：你们这些人类
Others: You humans
Shure: 我靠气死我了
Shure: Damn it, I'm so pissed
Shure: 吃太多叶黄素皮肤会变黄吗
Shure: Does eating too much lutein make your skin yellow?
Shure: 嘟嘟嘟
Shure: Doot doot doot
其他人：活鱼逆流而上
Others: Live fish swim upstream
其他人：死鱼随波逐流
Others: Dead fish go with the flow
Shure: 火车驶向云
Shure: The train heads to the clouds
Shure: 外蒙韩文宇九霄
Shure: Outer Mongolia, Han Wen Yu Jiuxiao
Shure: 这他妈是上下联
Shure: This is a couplet
其他人：你知道
Others: You know
其他人：我那个叶黄素胶囊就是正常20毫克
Others: My lutein capsules are normally 20mg
其他人：我那个一颗是40毫克
Others: Mine are 40mg each
其他人：是可逆的
Others: It's reversible
其他人：逐渐啊
Others: Gradually, yeah
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
其他人：爬上去了啊
Others: Climb up, yeah
其他人：宝宝我回来了
Others: Baby, I'm back
其他人：你还是一只小猫
Others: You're still a little kitten
其他人：走吧
Others: Let's go
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is it?
Shure: 他为什么会突然醒
Shure: Why did he suddenly wake up?
Shure: 不啊啊啊
Shure: Nooo!
其他人：咦
Others: Huh?
其他人：小狸小狸
Others: Tasha, Tasha!
Shure: 台球
Shure: Billiards.
Shure: 台球哎
Shure: Billiards, huh.
Shure: 好可惜
Shure: Such a pity.
其他人：（歌词）牛羊自由自在的跳舞
Others: (Lyrics) The cows and sheep dance freely.
其他人：那边绿灯了所以我们要快过去
Others: The light's green over there, so we should hurry.
Shure: 好的好的好的嗯好的
Shure: Okay, okay, okay, sure.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎好吃
Shure: Oh, tasty.
其他人：当饭后消食了出来是
Others: Came out to digest after the meal.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 烟酒店是什么
Shure: What is a liquor store?
Shure: 酒店哈哈哈
Shure: A hotel, haha.
其他人：这是我最真诚的故乡
Others: This is my most sincere hometown.
Shure: 你的故乡关门了
Shure: Your hometown is closed.
Shure: 你怎么逐渐修化了
Shure: Why are you becoming more polished?
其他人：你就不要
Others: You just don't...
Shure: 那你给我雕一个
Shure: Then carve one for me.
其他人：我给你雕什么
Others: Carve what for you?
其他人：雕不了一点
Others: Can't carve anything.
其他人：特价48元一只四大名鸡
Others: Special price, 48 yuan each, Four Famous Chickens.
Shure: 被你发现了吗
Shure: Did you find out?
其他人：什么
Others: What?
Shure: 我说四大名
Shure: I said Four Great...
Shure: 哈哈哈什么哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, what, hahaha.
其他人：什么
Others: What?
Shure: 我是starming yeah
Shure: I'm starming, yeah.
其他人：不买彩票的吗
Others: Aren't you buying lottery tickets?
其他人： 不买刮刮乐的吗可能
Others: Not buying scratch-offs? Maybe.
Shure: 精神比较富足吧
Shure: Spiritually rich.
Shure: 不需要靠这些哦
Shure: Don't need these.
Shure: 哎咱那号啊
Shure: Hey, that number of ours...
Shure: 太硬了只能说
Shure: It's too hard to say.
Shure: 那号真的是太硬了
Shure: That number is really tough.
其他人：生活超市
Others: Life supermarket.
Shure: 呵呵我害怕了
Shure: Haha, I'm scared.
Shure: 剪发配眼镜
Shure: Haircut and glasses.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 我
Shure: I
Shure: 23或者2523就是明天
Shure: 23 or 25... 23 is tomorrow
Shure: 那不行那肯定得25了
Shure: That won't work, it definitely has to be the 25th.
其他人：24为什么不行
Others: Why not the 24th?
其他人：24不是好日子吗
Others: Isn't the 24th a good day?
Shure: 24不是好日子哦
Shure: The 24th is not a good day.
Shure: 24是你离开北京的日子
Shure: The 24th is the day you leave Beijing.
Shure: 24我去送你吗
Shure: Should I see you off on the 24th?
其他人：妈呀五六点你去送我吗
Others: Oh my, at five or six in the morning, you'll see me off?
Shure: 我送你一下吧
Shure: I'll see you off.
Shure: 然后再从大兴去上班
Shure: Then go to work from Daxing.
Shure: 感动吗
Shure: Touched?
其他人：对角线
Others: Diagonal route.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Shure: 所以我跑也可能进去
Shure: So I might run and get in.
Shure: 进到安检前面啊没事
Shure: Get through security, it's fine.
Shure: 送送你
Shure: I'll see you off.
Shure: 如果我起来的话
Shure: If I wake up.
其他人： 我都不一定能起来
Others: I might not even wake up.
Shure: 那我得起来叫叫你哈哈哈
Shure: Then I'll have to wake you up, haha.
Shure: 主要退票手续费怪贵的啊
Shure: Mainly because the ticket cancellation fee is so expensive.
Shure: 主要退票手续费怪贵的
Shure: 我倒不心疼
Shure: I don't mind.
Shure: 你去不去上海
Shure: Are you going to Shanghai?
Shure: 这个是那个那个叫
Shure: This is, um, um called...
其他人：我靠梦幻丽莎发廊
Others: Whoa, Dreamy Lisa Salon.
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 我说这个他唱的
Shure: I mean this, the song he sang.
其他人：我我是说我是说这是那张专辑里啊
Others: I mean, I mean it's from that album.
Shure: 我我说这个
Shure: I mean this...
Shure: 任科和谁来着
Shure: Ren Ke and who again?
Shure: 另一个叫什么来着啊
Shure: What's the other guy's name again?
Shure: 孟浩涛对孟浩涛
Shure: Meng Haotao, yes Meng Haotao.
Shure: 我就突然想不起来他的名字了
Shure: I just suddenly couldn't remember his name.
Shure: 我们应该从这过马路的吧
Shure: Should we cross the street here?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：哈哈哈等半天没等到
Others: Haha, we waited for so long.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: （歌词）全都是泡沫
Shure: (Lyrics) It's all bubbles.
Shure: 腰带真的没有用啊
Shure: The belt is really useless.
Shure: 这不也能
Shure: See, it still works.
其他人：真的因为他底下是那个什么
Others: Yeah, because underneath it has something.
Shure: 他后面是死的
Shure: It's fixed at the back.
其他人：他后面是个松紧
Others: The back is elastic.
其他人：对所以根本不需要腰带
Others: Right, so there's no need for a belt at all.
Shure: 那嘎达
Shure: That thing.
Shure: 我哥说今天活很多
Shure: My brother said there's a lot of work today.
Shure: 说他会陆续给我发
Shure: He said he'd send it to me gradually.
Shure: 结果一个都没发
Shure: But he didn't send a single one.
Shure: 我现在很慌
Shure: Now I'm really panicking.
Shure: 给他自个忘了
Shure: He probably forgot himself.
其他人： 他会不会在飞机上
Others: Maybe he's on a plane.
Shure: 他今天好像要去什么发布会啊
Shure: He seems to have an event or something today.
Shure: 好像是他那个新的厂牌的发布会
Shure: It's for his new label's launch.
其他人：我以为出差是往外飞呢
Others: I thought a business trip meant flying out.
Shure: 我不知道在不在北京
Shure: I don't know if he's in Beijing.
Shure: 有可能在北京
Shure: Maybe he's in Beijing.
Shure: 跟巴巴rising那个厂牌
Shure: With that BABA Rising label.
Shure: 弄了一个厂牌
Shure: Made a label.
Shure: 然后找了傅涵
Shure: Then got Fu Han.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 他们最开始想找刘恋
Shure: At first, they wanted to get Liu Lian.
Shure: 然后不知道为什么后来就找成傅涵了
Shure: Then for some reason, they got Fu Han instead.
其他人：刘恋最近很忙吧
Others: Liu Lian is really busy lately.
其他人：生日会
Others: Birthday party.
Shure: 真觉得不如找找刘恋找傅晗
Shure: Honestly, finding Liu Lian would have been better than Fu Han.
Shure: 哎真不容易
Shure: It's really not easy.
Shure: 生完孩子就得出来赚奶粉钱
Shure: Just had a baby and already has to earn money for formula.
Shure: 你说他演出他会带娃去哈哈哈
Shure: Do you think he'd take the baby to his performances? Hahaha.
Shure: 哦也是
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure: 听说傅涵最近的
Shure: I heard Fu Han recently
Shure: 发挥实力还是
Shure: is still performing well.
Shure: 一如既往的好
Shure: As good as always.
Shure: 就是脑袋里面的黄色废料太多了
Shure: But his head is full of dirty thoughts.
Shure: 流出来了
Shure: They're spilling out.
Shure: 嗯你想想吧
Shure: Think about it.
Shure: 脑袋里装了多少黄色东西
Shure: How much dirty stuff is in his head?
Shure: 整个皮肤都是
Shure: His whole skin is
Shure: 叫什么黄的
Shure: what you call yellow.
Shure: 流油是吧哇
Shure: It's so greasy, wow.
Shure: 都是靓仔
Shure: Everyone here is handsome.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh my.
Shure: 哎为什么两边都红的
Shure: Hey, why are both sides red?
其他人：我感觉都到这了我下午可以去趟环球
Others: I feel like we've come this far, I can go to Universal this afternoon.
Shure: no
Shure: No.
其他人：什么no
Others: What do you mean, no?
Shure: 你不能抛弃我的
Shure: You can't abandon me.
其他人：我就抛弃你了
Others: I'm abandoning you.
Shure: 你抛弃我我会哭的
Shure: If you abandon me, I'll cry.
其他人：看看
Others: Look at that.
Shure: 你怎么兴奋了
Shure: Why are you so excited?
Shure: 哎怎么了
Shure: Hey, what's up?
其他人：跟穿上裙子一样
Others: It's like wearing a skirt.
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's wrong?
其他人：没事
Others: Nothing.
其他人：笑死了
Others: So funny.
其他人：我那天那天去逛奥森不是穿裙子了吗
Others: The other day when I went to Olympic Forest Park, I wore a skirt.
其他人：啊然后然后那天特别热
Others: Ah, and then it was really hot that day.
其他人：呃我上午去开会的时候
Others: Uh, when I went to the meeting in the morning.
其他人：穿的是这条裤子啊
Others: I was wearing these pants.
其他人：然后
Others: And then.
其他人：然后我那个问Derry要不要出门的时候
Others: Then when I asked Derry if he wanted to go out.
其他人：就本来打算自己去
Others: I originally planned to go alone.
其他人：然后正好看到他发微博
Others: And then I saw he posted on Weibo.
其他人：然后我就问一句然后一块去了嘛
Others: So I asked him, and we went together.
其他人：然后嗯然后我在那想
Others: Then, um, then I was thinking.
其他人：我说要不我下午换件衣服吧
Others: I thought maybe I should change my clothes in the afternoon.
其他人：他一直在说从来没见过我穿裙子
Others: He kept saying he'd never seen me in a skirt.
其他人：我说不可能
Others: I said, no way.
其他人：你肯定见过
Others: You must have.
其他人：只是你没有意识到
Others: You just didn't realize it.
其他人：就是就是
Others: Exactly, exactly.
其他人：有些刻板印象
Others: It's just some stereotypes.
Shure: 刻板印象可还行
Shure: Stereotypes, right?
其他人：就刻板印象
Others: Just stereotypes.
其他人：就觉得啊男人穿裙子啊就这种
Others: Thinking, ah, men wearing skirts, that kind of thing.
其他人：然后我那天说好决定了今天穿裙子
Others: Then I said, okay, I've decided to wear a skirt today.
其他人：他说
Others: He said.
其他人：你不要穿一条像裙子的裤子来糊弄我
Others: Don't try to fool me by wearing pants that look like a skirt.
其他人：呵呵我说我说虽然上午是这么穿的
Others: Haha, I said, even though I wore this in the morning,
其他人：但下午肯定不会了
Others: I definitely won't in the afternoon.
其他人：然后他说哦
Others: And then he said, oh,
其他人：那你下午不会是要穿一条
Others: are you going to wear something like
其他人：像裤子的裙子吧哈哈哈
Others: pants that look like a skirt in the afternoon? Hahaha.
其他人：走从这上二楼啊
Others: Let's go up to the second floor from here.
Shure: 我不会多走了这么多吧
Shure: I wouldn't have walked this much, right?
Shure: 如果他真的有的话
Shure: If he really has it,
Shure: 我真的会崩溃的你知道吗
Shure: I would really break down, you know?
其他人：不要崩溃
Others: Don't break down.
其他人：遛弯了嘛
Others: Just taking a walk.
Shure: 哇好吧
Shure: Wow, so scared.
Shure: 我说现在我没喝咖啡
Shure: I said, I haven't had coffee now.
Shure: 我人是
Shure: I'm like,
Shure: 懵的你知道吗
Shure: confused, you know?
其他人：都怪我
Others: It's all my fault.
Shure: 哈哈哈我真的就以为自己喝过了草
Shure: Hahaha, I really thought I had some grass.
Shure: 我真服了呀
Shure: I'm really impressed.
Shure: 啊没开
Shure: Ah, it's not open.
Shure: 我瞅一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
Shure: 我开着还是没开
Shure: Is it open or not?
其他人：签字
Others: Sign it.
其他人：好不要担心
Others: Okay, don't worry.
其他人：你的疑虑没有成真
Others: Your worries didn't come true.
Shure: 太好了
Shure: That's great.
其他人：啦啦啦啦
Others: La la la la.
Shure: 蝴蝶棱镜
Shure: Butterfly Prism.
Shure: 这好摇滚啊
Shure: This is so rock.
Shure: 这个这个样子哈哈哈
Shure: This, this look, hahaha.
Shure: 这个名字
Shure: This name,
Shure: 蝴蝶棱镜
Shure: Butterfly Prism.
其他人：摇滚应该是那种流行
Others: Rock should be that kind of pop.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Shure: 哒哒哒
Shure: Da da da.
其他人：西瓜会挑吗
Others: Can you pick a watermelon?
Shure: 不会啊你会吗
Shure: No, can you?
其他人：呃会但是不一定准
Others: Uh, yes, but not always accurate.
Shure: 那你就挑吧
Shure: Then you pick it.
Shure: 你别挑反的就行
Shure: Just don't pick the wrong one.
其他人：那拿两个小的
Others: Then take two small ones.
Shure: 那么大的吃
Shure: That's a huge piece.
其他人：拿个大的
Others: Take a big one.
Shure: 也别太大
Shure: But not too big.
Shure: 弄一个弄半个
Shure: Get one or half of one.
其他人：这个应该很甜
Others: This should be very sweet.
其他人： 这个应该怎么挑都甜
Others: This one should be sweet no matter what.
其他人：要一个要半个
Others: Get one or half of one.
Shure: 要一个要半个
Shure: Get one or half of one.
Shure: 8个人 8个人一个够吧
Shure: Eight people, one should be enough, right?
Shure: 应该一个肯定够了
Shure: One should definitely be enough.
Shure: 半个
Shure: Half.
其他人：半个会不会有点少
Others: Would half be too little?
其他人：8个人半个肯定不够啊
Others: Half wouldn't be enough for eight people.
其他人：拿一个吧拿一个吧好
Others: Let's get one, one is fine.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 帮你先拿着
Shure: Let me hold it for you.
Shure: 哈哈帮你拿手机
Shure: Haha, let me hold your phone.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
其他人：拿这个吧
Others: Take this one.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
其他人：以为你拿我手机是要付钱呀
Others: I thought you were taking my phone to pay.
Shure: 呵
Shure: Heh.
Shure: 又不是不能报销
Shure: It's not like we can't get reimbursed.
Shure: 应该可以吧
Shure: It should be okay, right?
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 你带路吧我绷着
Shure: You lead the way, I'll follow.
Shure: 啊咱俩是从这边来的吗
Shure: Uh, did we come from this way?
其他人：就是我们是那样
Others: Yeah, we did.
其他人：其实这样也可以啊啊
Others: Actually, this way works too.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 反正你带路吧
Shure: You lead the way anyway.
Shure: 我只要换一点道我都找不到了
Shure: I get lost if the route changes even a bit.
Shure: 当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun.
Shure: 每次捧着西瓜都
Shure: Every time I hold a watermelon,
Shure: 脑袋里面就想起了猪八戒背媳妇的BGM
Shure: I think of the background music from Pigsy carrying his wife.
其他人：哈哈猪八戒背媳妇的BGM
Others: Haha, Pigsy carrying his wife background music.
Shure: 当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun dun.
其他人：油漆未干
Others: Paint not dry.
Shure: 我很好奇是不是真的未干
Shure: I'm really curious if it's actually wet.
其他人：假的呀
Others: It's fake.
Shure: 那你坐下去吧
Shure: Then you sit down.
Shure: 刀闪靓仔呦
Shure: The knife looks shiny, dude.
Shure: 扔金砖了
Shure: Throwing gold bars.
Shure: 这比比我们做的好啊
Shure: This is better than what we did.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈幼儿园
Shure: Hahaha, kindergarten.
其他人：幼儿园
Others: Kindergarten.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: （歌词）所有过往都找到那权利的借口
Shure: (Lyrics) All the past found excuses for that power.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
其他人：青蛙
Others: Frog.
Shure: 对听取蛙声一片在哪呢
Shure: Yeah, where's the sound of frogs?
Shure: 好臭啊走啊
Shure: It stinks, let's go.
其他人：光球叫求偶呢啊
Others: The light ball is calling for a mate.
Shure: 你怎么知道他们是求偶呢
Shure: How do you know they're calling for a mate?
其他人：因为我背过动物行为学那本书
Others: Because I memorized the animal behavior book.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 咦
Shure: Eww.
Shure: 那我在大喊大叫是为了什么
Shure: Then why am I shouting loudly?
Shure: 也是为了求偶吗哈哈哈
Shure: Is it also to find a mate? Hahaha.
Shure: 动物行为学和人类行为学
Shure: Animal behavior and human behavior.
Shure: 有本质区别吗
Shure: Are they fundamentally different?
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
其他人：某种意义上来讲
Others: In a way.
其他人：人也是动物的哦
Others: Humans are animals too, you know.
其他人：那那我抱吧我抱吧
Others: Then let me hold it, let me hold it.
Shure: 没事别别别
Shure: No, no, no, it's fine.
其他人：一会碎了
Others: It'll break in a bit.
Shure: 一会回去
Shure: We'll take it back later.
Shure: 看着多丢人啊
Shure: It's so embarrassing to see.
其他人：到门口你再接过去啊
Others: You can take it at the door.
Shure: 那钱呀我球球能干那种事情哈哈哈
Shure: That money, yeah, I can do that kind of thing, hahaha.
Shure: 口闲体直
Shure: Saying no but meaning yes.
Shure: 的花这什么花
Shure: The flowers, what kind of flowers are these?
其他人：松松松果的那个
Others: Pine cones, the ones.
其他人：松子的那个
Others: The pine nuts.
其他人：结的小松子
Others: The little pine nuts they grow.
其他人：然后他长长就会长城
Others: Then they will grow into a long pine cone.
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
Shure: 松果
Shure: Pine cones.
其他人：哦花絮
Others: Oh, bloopers.
其他人：哼你说这个那天那天告告告诉森
Others: Hmph, you said that day, that day, tell Sen
其他人：然后看那个苹果花
Others: And then look at that apple blossom
其他人：那边苹果花刚开
Others: The apple blossom just bloomed over there
其他人：然后我说哦
Others: And I said, oh
其他人：这个是苹果花
Others: This is an apple blossom
其他人：然后戴瑞真的吗
Others: And then Dary, really?
其他人：什么味道
Others: What does it taste like?
其他人：然后摘了片花叶在那嚼
Others: Then he picked a petal and chewed on it
其他人：然后在那嚼嚼嚼
Others: And then he chewed, chewed, chewed
其他人：我说什么味道
Others: I asked, what does it taste like?
其他人：他说不好说
Others: He said, it's hard to describe
其他人：然后我也摘一片嚼嚼嚼
Others: So I picked a petal too and chewed, chewed, chewed
其他人：一股苹果皮的味道
Others: It tastes like apple peel
Shure: 那个花真的吗
Shure: Is that flower real?
其他人：对
Others: Yes
Shure: 我明天回单位我也尝尝去
Shure: I'll go back to the office tomorrow and try it too
其他人：但他那个花特别薄所以
Others: But that flower is very thin, so
其他人：就是不像玉兰
Others: It's not like magnolia
其他人：玉兰的话它这个花瓣是有厚度的
Others: Magnolia petals have some thickness
其他人：然后这个没有
Others: And this one doesn't
其他人：味道不是很浓
Others: The taste is not very strong
其他人：（歌词）我敢听他说些不着边
Others: (Lyrics) I dare to listen to him talking nonsense
Shure: （歌词）的花丛里与你一起谈谈
Shure: (Lyrics) Talking with you in the flower bushes
Shure: （歌词）理想好吧
Shure: (Lyrics) Ideal, okay?
Shure: 味对了吧
Shure: The taste is right, isn't it?
其他人：对了
Others: Yes, it is
Shure: 哦他在修路啊
Shure: Oh, he's fixing the road
Shure: 噢不是嗨
Shure: Oh, not... Hi
Shure: 我以为这是哪工厂的呢
Shure: I thought this was some factory
Shure: 他只是在修路
Shure: He's just fixing the road
Shure: 修修修路
Shure: Fixing, fixing the road
Shure: 就是走到这然后右拐
Shure: Just walk here and then turn right
Shure: 然后我以为他走不了了呢
Shure: I thought he couldn't walk anymore
Shure: 所以我就以为我走错了
Shure: So I thought I went the wrong way
Shure: 啊哈哈哈哈
Shure: Ahahaha
Shure: 你要在极度困的时候就不想做咖啡
Shure: When you're extremely tired, you don't want to make coffee
Shure: 整个人就白了
Shure: You just go pale
其他人：嚼嚼生嚼咖啡豆
Others: Chew raw coffee beans
Shure: 没有用
Shure: It's useless
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure: 之前那个上高中的时候有时候着急
Shure: Back in high school, sometimes I was in a rush.
Shure: 早上奶泡都不整了
Shure: I wouldn't even bother with the milk foam in the morning.
Shure: 直接啪两那个弄出来一烧的
Shure: I'd just quickly make a couple of shots and heat them up.
Shure: 然后咵肘了
Shure: Then I'd chug it down.
Shure: 然后就走了
Shure: And then I'd go.
其他人：如果我那么喝我真的会有点醉
Others: If I drank like that, I'd really get a bit tipsy.
其他人：咖啡因
Others: From the caffeine.
Shure: 啥都醉一天天
Shure: You get tipsy from everything, every day.
其他人：我前两天我在那跟你说我说不行
Others: The other day, I was telling you I couldn't handle it.
其他人：我感觉喝了之后有点晕就是因为
Others: I felt dizzy after drinking because it was really strong.
其他人：浓度特别高的一小杯
Others: Just a small cup with very high concentration.
Shure: 你家的面条特好吃
Shure: Your noodles are really delicious.
Shure: 谁家的面条
Shure: Whose noodles?
其他人：谁家我家
Others: Whose, mine?
Shure: 你家我们家
Shure: Yours, ours.
Shure: 因为有酸菜卤
Shure: Because they have pickled vegetables.
Shure: 哈哈哦哎sorry
Shure: Haha, oh, sorry.
其他人：呦
Others: Oh.
Shure: 就是这个还不是东北的特色
Shure: This isn't even a specialty of the northeast.
Shure: 就是我们家这么做而已
Shure: It's just how we make it at home.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 不能被发现
Shure: Can't be found out.
Shure: 不能吃酸菜哦
Shure: Can't eat pickled vegetables.
Shure: 不然话不让进门
Shure: Or else, won't be let in the house.
其他人：哦太好了
Others: Oh, that's great.
其他人：笑死我了
Others: That's hilarious.
其他人：什么长远打算
Others: Any long-term plans?
其他人：救命
Others: Help me.
其他人：你有长远打算吗
Others: Do you have any long-term plans?
Shure: 我们昨天晚上不是讨论一晚上吗
Shure: Didn't we discuss it all night yesterday?
其他人：呵呵不是不是
Others: Haha, no, no.
其他人：哎呀
Others: Oh, come on.
其他人：什么呀哈哈
Others: What? Haha.
其他人：好吧好吧
Others: Okay, okay.
Shure: 还双语谈论的
Shure: We even discussed it bilingually.
Shure: 哎呦天呐
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 然后你搞得我有时候也
Shure: And then you got me sometimes...
Shure: 我也切不过来了
Shure: I get so confused.
Shure: 然后我说跟现在
Shure: And I said to myself...
其他人：我是真有点切不过来
Others: I really get confused sometimes.
其他人：我感觉我明天还会更严重
Others: I feel like it'll be worse tomorrow.
Shure: 哎天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 以后dirty talk都变成English了是吗
Shure: Are we switching to dirty talk in English from now on?
其他人：这玩意用中文可以吗
Others: Can we use Chinese for this?
其他人：哈哈有点怪吧
Others: Haha, it's kinda weird, right?
Shure: 用中文可以
Shure: Using Chinese is fine.
Shure: 不是这个不是这个
Shure: Not this, not this.
Shure: 明天就不是休老师变成Mr休了是吗
Shure: So tomorrow, I'll be Mr. Xiu instead of Teacher Xiu?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahaha.
其他人：哦30 哦那31和51
Others: Oh, 30. Oh, then 31 and 51.
其他人：是什么颜色哦
Others: What color are they?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 杨老板开门
Shure: Jake, open the door.
Shure: 我是我哥
Shure: It's me, bro.
其他人：呵呵呵呵
Others: Hehehe.
其他人：你是你哥
Others: You're your brother?
Shure: 嫂子开门
Shure: Sis-in-law, open the door.
Shure: 我是我哥
Shure: It's me, bro.
Shure: 谢谢嫂子
Shure: Thanks, sis-in-law.
Shure: 哎给大家买了个西瓜
Shure: Hey, I bought a watermelon for everyone.
Shure: 这
Shure: This.
Shure: 你咋了啊你
Shure: What's up with you?
Lucia: 我有点头晕
Lucia: I'm a little dizzy.
Shure: 头晕真的只是喝多了
Shure: Dizzy? You probably just drank too much.
Shure: 没有问题的啊
Shure: It's no big deal.
其他人：你从你从位置开始哈哈哈
Others: Start from your spot, hahaha.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Shure: 在楼上干嘛
Shure: What are you doing upstairs?
Shure: 买了西瓜
Shure: Bought a watermelon.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Shure: 哎呦我靠
Shure: Oh damn.
Shure: 大家切瓜吃瓜吧好
Shure: Everyone, let's cut the watermelon and eat.
Jake:好吃吃瓜多吃瓜
Jake: Yeah, eat the watermelon, eat more.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:音响收一收
Jake: Put the speakers away.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 那要镇上吗那个西瓜
Shure: Should we take the watermelon to town?
Jake:huh
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 那西瓜要镇一下吗
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 怎么镇
Shure: How do we chill it?
Shure: 好的收拾收拾
Shure: Alright, let's clean up a bit.
Jake:哎呀捡钱了
Jake: Oh, found some money!
Shure: 怎么了你
Shure: What's up with you?
其他人：刚你刚那个把扇子有点那个声音
Others: Just now, the fan made some noise.
其他人：听了吓吓吓吓了一下
Others: It startled us a bit.
Shure: 一般冰镇不是都拿冰扔到井里吗
Shure: Usually, don’t we chill things by throwing ice into the well?
Shure: 哈哈哈是吧
Shure: Haha, right?
其他人：他这个放不开
Others: He can't let it go.
其他人：你放楼上吧行
Others: Just put it upstairs, alright.
Shure: 好啊
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 宕机了
Shure: Crashed.
其他人：喝咖啡吗你是的
Others: Did you have coffee?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 宕机了我
Shure: I crashed.
Shure: 你请坐
Shure: Please have a seat.
Shure: 网易的袋子
Shure: NetEase bag.
Shure: 我在网易上面4个大字生活美好
Shure: On NetEase, it says "Life is Beautiful."
其他人：这个就看不见
Others: You can't see it.
Shure: 真的看不见
Shure: You really can't see it.
Shure: 哎但是我在网易可以说是吃的很好
Shure: But I have to say, I eat really well at NetEase.
Shure: 真挺好吃的
Shure: It's really delicious.
Shure: 我靠作为一个食堂来讲
Shure: As far as cafeterias go.
Shure: 要不周二来一趟吧
Shure: How about we go there on Tuesday?
其他人： 啊什么
Others: Huh, what?
Shure: 尝尝
Shure: Give it a try.
Shure: 吃不上啊
Shure: Can't get in?
其他人：哎我今天看到做动画就是呃
Others: Hey, today I saw an animation, you know...
其他人：董董亚谦那个欲望还乡
Others: By Dong Yaqian, "Desire Returns Home."
其他人：继续哆啦a梦那一段可有意思了
Others: That part with Doraemon was so interesting.
Shure: 什么动画
Shure: What animation?
其他人：速速购入北京邮电大学周边
Others: Quickly buy the Beijing University of Posts and Telecommunications merchandise.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What stuff?
其他人：帽子衣服伞包
Others: Hats, clothes, umbrellas, bags.
其他人：（歌词）我还想继续做遗忘
Others: (lyrics) I still want to continue to forget.
Jake:刮着什么了呀
Jake: What are you scratching?
Jake:刮到啥了呀
Jake: What did you scratch?
Shure: 什么刮到什么
Shure: Scratch what?
Jake:刮刮刮乐刮啊
Jake: Scratch, scratch the scratch-off ticket
Shure: 没买到没买到
Shure: Didn't get it, didn't get it
Jake:没买到
Jake: Didn't get it
Jake:哈哈哈没买到是什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what do you mean you didn't get it?
Shure: 然后所以就买了个瓜回来
Shure: So I bought a melon instead
Jake:为什么不开了
Jake: Why isn't it open?
Jake:倒闭了不是被人没
Jake: Did it close down or something?
Shure: 没没去那家
Shure: No, I didn't go to that one
Shure: 有一家更近的
Shure: There's one that's closer
Shure: 然后我就去那那家
Shure: So I went to that one
Shure: 结果发现他不卖刮刮乐
Shure: But they don't sell scratch-offs
Shure: 他只卖那种传统的那种打号的哦
Shure: They only sell the traditional numbered tickets
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 啪啪啪啪啪啪
Tasha: Clap, clap, clap, clap
Shure: 哎气死
Shure: Ugh, so frustrating
Shure: 我了
Shure: Really
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then
Shure: 然后就买了个瓜
Shure: So I just bought a melon
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Jake:镇镇镇一镇
Jake: Let's settle down for a bit
Shure: 这没地
Shure: There's no space
Jake:那上楼镇一镇
Jake: Then let's settle upstairs
Jake:大伙吃瓜
Jake: Everyone, let's eat the melon